good morning John I'm in Seattle and I'm
very tired and traveling with the
two-year-old is very easy and also
vegetarian sandwiches in Montana are not
the saddest thing ever
all right I'm going to if this is okay
and it doesn't matter if it's not cuz no
one's here to tell me otherwise continue
the discussion that we've been having
for the last two videos last week even
before you put your video out I tweeted
a tweet that you of course did not see
because you are not on Twitter unless
you probably don't even know that the
President of the United States invited a
football team to the White House to eat
McDonald the sweet red thusly for the
people who want my most recent video can
you tell me one healthy thing that fuels
you and one unhealthy thing that fuels
you all start one I feel good when I
help other people experience joy to I
feel good when I am more successful than
people who I dislike this actually
spawned a great deal of surprisingly
healthy conversation on Twitter I'm
actually kind of proud of it it was like
I used Twitter to do a good thing of
course later on I undid all this hard
work by tweeting this so you know but I
heard from so many smart people with
good thoughts about healthy and
unhealthy fuels and it made me think a
lot of things and there are certainly
many more interesting things to think
about this than the ones I'm about to
throw at you but here are a few things
that I thought that I think are
interests people's healthy fuels were
commonly about one of two things one
positive emotions about other people
like love loyalty even an obligation to
other people or to like humanity as a
whole or to a feeling of like progress
of doing something that you're really
good at which is really an interesting
one to me because it seems like it's
possible for this one to exist without
even internal or external validation
it's just there and it just feels good
that one seems very rare and precious
and I want to find it more second
people's unhealthy fuels were often
though they were I feel like a wider
variety of these seated in one of these
two things one negative feelings about
other people lots of people just wrote
the word spite and had that to be done
with but also like general revenge or
anger or even fear of other people too
and this was I think the most common one
negative feelings about yourself and
this wasn't like I'm afraid I'm going to
disappoint my parents because that's
your parents emotion this was I'm afraid
I'm going to be disappointing and that
is surprisingly a different thing like
being afraid that you're going to
disappoint someone else versus like
being a disappointment in total very
different though they sound exactly the
same and the third thing I thought John
especially as I read a lot of comments
from people who I really admire and
respect and who have done what I
consider to be really wonderful things
is that I think that you can burn
unhealthy fuels and have a good outcome
and you talked about in your video that
you weren't able to like right
what like the good parts of Looking for
Alaska until you found a healthier fuel
to burn but I think that it is possible
to do good things with unhealthy fuels
and I have not shied away from at times
burning those unhealthy fuels but I
think that the important thing is that
we recognize what they are when we're
doing it and and that there might be a
long-term negative outcome it's almost
like taking on cognitive debt but just
like when you're taking on debt you got
to recognize that when you're doing it
you should be doing it for really good
reasons and also that there might
eventually or even right now be
alternatives some kind of alternative
fuel that might be a little less
efficient might burn a little less
bright but might be a whole lot more
sustainable you got to get some solar
panels up on your psyche everybody John
those are the things that I wanted to
say I got to go do pod con stuff now
I'll see you on Tuesday or the other
room now saying POC ha pod Cod can you
Orin can you say pod con